>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
>> Robert Patrick:
Well, good afternoon.
I think I know most of
you but for those of you
who don't know me I'm Bob Patrick.
I'm the director of the Veterans
History Project here at the Library
of Congress and we're
actually thrilled today
to be able to sponsor this program.
We always welcome people who
are on the same road with us,
people who have an affinity for
veterans, who interview veterans,
who do creative things
around veterans.
It's always good to welcome someone
on board with us in that way.
Just a little bit about the
Veterans History Project.
The Veterans History Project
here at the Library of Congress
in our 15th year is a Congressional
mandate to collect and preserve
and make accessible the wartime
memories of America's veterans
and as I said we've been doing
that for the last 15 years.
We've accumulated an archive of
just short of 100,000 collections
of veterans from World
War I all the way
up to the current conflicts
of today.
That is an ongoing process that
has been done through the efforts
of volunteers literally across the
country, every state in the union,
every congressional district,
everywhere across the states people
have been sending in their stories
of America's veterans
so we get some hundred
or so collections every
week that come into us.
We do this primarily through oral
histories of people sitting down
and interviewing what we call
the veteran in their life
and it could be someone in their
family, someone in their community,
someone they worship with,
someone they shop with
or someone they just don't know
but they've become an acquaintance,
and we encourage people to do that.
So whenever I come out to a venue
like this or even run into somebody
on the street I asked them who
is the veteran in your life
and each one of us has
a veteran in their life.
It may not be a family member but
it may be what I just talked about,
it's someone that you know
or someone you run into
or someone that's just
an acquaintance
through a friend of
a friend or whatever.
And I would encourage you
to think about participating
in the Veterans History Project.
If you don't know it there is
an information center down here
on the first floor in
the Madison Building,
Room LM 109, an information center.
We can get more information
about interviewing veterans.
We have our field kit that
we can hand out to you
that tells you everything you need
to know about interviewing a veteran
or collecting materials if a
veteran has passed on things
like photographs, letters,
diaries and we'll hear a little bit
about photographs today
and you'll get a sense
of what treasures those can
be for projects such as ours
and if you want to
take it a step further,
just another small
advertisement, this is a document
that was recently published that
is doing veterans oral history
and we're very proud of
this because this was done
through the Oral History
Association here in America.
We worked with them,
professional oral historian,
put this book together and it tells
you in a little bit more detail
than what we tell you in our field
kit about how to interview veterans.
This is available.
If you'd like to get it
we'll talk to you later
about how you can get a copy of it
but it really is taking
it a step further
and I'm really proud
that we have this now.
So enough about the project,
let's talk about our guest today.
Adam Harrison Levy is a
writer and a freelance
and documentary film
producer and director
and as I said he has
interviewed veterans.
He knows veterans.
He's worked for the BBC and
documentaries on from D-Day
to Berlin and in the
Nuremberg trials as well
as the photographic gallery
exhibition on Hiroshima.
He is currently treaching
at the School of Visual Arts
in New York City but
previously has been
with Wesleyan University
and Yale University.
If you've read the promo to
this particular talk it talks
about a suitcase full of
photographs of Hiroshima
and some other veterans
involved in this
and intertwining this
into nonfiction.
I'll leave it at that and turn
it over to Adam Levy Harrison,
excuse me, let's try this again,
Adam Harrison Levy, excuse me -
[ Applause ]
>> Adam Harrison Levy:
Thank you all for turning
out on a Friday afternoon.
Thank you Bob and thank you
Monica for inviting me here.
It is an honor definitely and I
guess today just to kind of sketch
out what to expect I'm going to
talk about some unknown photographs
from the beaches of D-Day which I
turned up a number of years ago,
I'll talk about that, a little
bit of a kind of philosophy
and methodology of interviewing
and then a cultural history
of the interview which I have to say
I'm putting together at the moment
and it starts with the 19th
century and moves up to the present.
It's definitely a subjective
history.
It's not the story but it's a story
and no one seems to have written
about the history of the
interview so I'm keen on them,
and the last part which
Bob mentioned is the story
of 700 photographs that were found
in a suitcase on a street corner
in Massachusetts and my a story
of how to figure out what happened
to those photographs and
how they came to be there.
So -
hopefully this will work.
Another click?
Okay. So as Bob mentioned I've been
working as a documentary filmmaker
and one of the things that we do
as researchers obviously is turn
up interviewees and turn
up documents and this was
about five years ago and I was
working on this big series with BBC
and it was finished, it was editing,
and the producer called me up
and said look we need this document
can you go find it and it was
at the Brown University Library
and I called the archivist there
and you know I'm sure a lot of you
are archivists, a wonderful breed,
know everything in sort of lateral
serendipitous ways and this man said
to me do you know Manuel Bromberg?
He was a U.S. war artist?
And I kicked myself because I had
been working on this for a year
and I'd never heard of him and
it was done and filming was done
and I thought well I have to
go check this U.S. war artist.
I didn't know anything about
the U.S. war artist program.
So I went to visit Manuel Bromberg.
He was in Woodstock, New York, in a
beautiful modern house and a ravine
that looks out over Woodstock
and I drove up, came to the door
and he greeted me very kind
of stately, impressive man
with a big strong brow and
swept back gray hair sort
of like you'd expect an 80-year-old
artist to look like and I went in
and it was very important
for interviewing to kind
of make that initial bond.
We sat down.
His wife brought us tea.
We talked for a little while.
I told him upfront that I
couldn't include him in the film
but I was very interested
in the story and his work
as a U.S. war artist
and then we went into --
, his wife cleared the table and we
went into the dining room and I took
out my tape recorder and took out my
notebook and started an interview.
So I think an interview should
feel like it's a conversation
but it's a conversation
with an agenda
and that agenda is held
by you, the interviewer.
So ideally that interview and
that agenda is not a rigid set
of unalterable questions but
something that's more fluid,
a narrative with a through line
like a plot but leaves room
for free association
and improvisation
so it's kind of like jazz.
There's a structure but within
that structure there's room to kind
of pick up on the free
association and improvise
and two important parts of that
is instinct and improvisation
and I should be clear that I'm
not a hard news interviewer.
I tried that once and it
was a complete disaster.
My style is to evoke
rather than to provoke
and for me an interview is something
that takes place between people.
It's literally an interview
and I like to think of it
as a collaboration between
myself and the interviewee
so in a way you're sort of helping
the interviewee articulate a version
of themselves or a
version of their memory
that maybe perhaps they haven't
articulated before to themselves.
So in that way a good interview
is never impersonal it's personal
and you become in effect a
partner in their own understanding
of themselves so it's a skill
that forces you to listen.
You have to train yourself literally
almost to get out of the way,
to shift attention
away from yourself
to focus the conversation
on the interviewee.
So in other words an
interview is a journey
into the interior landscape
of another person.
At the core you are asking
what is it like to be you?
So the question what is it
like to be you has a history.
As a journalistic genre
the interview evolved
in the mid-19th century from
verbatim printed court reports
in newspapers using direct
dialogue but as in August, 1859,
when a journalist Horace
Greeley [phonetic] traveled
to Salt Lake City to
interview Brigham Young
that most historians agree
the first interview took place
and it was interesting that it was
in a question and answer format
that we recognize now and it was
quite respectful but also pointed,
especially on polygamy
as you can expect.
Everyone wanted to know about
polygamy with the Mormon religion.
And Greeley questioned Young
respectfully and Young replied
that he had 13 wives and we now
know it's closer probably to 70
so there's a little bit of as
always in interviews a little bit
of shading of the truth there
right at the very beginning.
So there's something about
that because in the origin
of the interview and
the fact that it comes
from trial court reporting
there is something
that shadows the whole genre
no matter how empathetic
or nuanced the interviewer
is because it's part inquiry,
part voyeurism and part cat
and mouse verbal exchange
so this journeying into someone's
interior landscape is inevitably
also a probe successful only
if the interviewer brings
back something meaningful
from this interior world.
So Saul Bellow, the
writer, understood this
when he described an
interview as being
like thumbprints on his jugular.
At its darkest there is an edge of
attack woven into the very form,
an attack aimed at
personal revelation,
the so-called killer interview
or jugular journalism.
Interestingly there was almost --
, there was a distrust of the
interview almost simultaneously
with its origin and here's
a story to illustrate this.
So in 1889 Richard
Kipling undertook a jury
to interview his literary
hero, Mark Twain.
After relating his difficulties
of finding Twain's house Kipling
succeeded in convincing Twain
to sit down for an interview.
They first discussed, and
it's incredibly boring,
copyright [laughter] if you
can believe it, two writers,
and then Kipling as he says
growing bold and feeling
that I had a few hundred thousand
folk at my back asked Twain
if he was planning on writing a
sequel to Tom Sawyer [laughter].
I had a notion of writing
a sequel of Tom Sawyer
in two ways replied Twain, in one I
would make him rise to great honor
and go to Congress and in the
other I would hang him [laughter].
Kipling was over awed by Twain.
"I should have ample time
to look back to that meeting
across the graves of days" he
wrote, "He spoke on and I listened,
groveling", but ironically
two years later
in 1892 Kipling himself
was a subject
of a request to be interviewed.
According to his wife's
diary two reporters
from Boston visited
them at their house.
Kipling was outraged at
their request and refused.
Interviewing he said "is a
crime, just as much of a crime
as an offense against my
person, as an assault and just
as much merits punishment.
It's cowardly and vile.
No respectable man would
ask it much less give it."
So I think this speaks
to the difference
between being the journalist
assailant as opposed
to the journalist victim or maybe it
speaks to the hypocrisy of writers.
So the growing popularity
of the interview
through the 19th century was fueled
by the rise of mass education,
mass-market publications and
evolving readership with a hunger
for a more intimate
understanding of the public figures.
It was also fueled I would suggest
by the development of realism
in a novel and an emphasis on
dialogue, scene and character
and central to all these changes
was the increasing importance
of women especially in terms
of education and the growth
of readership in newspapers
and in mass publications
so the word interview in
the journalistic sense
of the word first appeared
in the OED in 1869
and ironically the same year the
nation said the interviewer present
managed is generally the form of
a joint product of some humbug
of a hack politician and another
humbug of a newspaper reporter
but the humbug was catching on.
In Britain where traditionalists
in the press opposed the interview
as a newfangled American invention
that lowered reading standards
it was called an epidemic.
In the first six months of 1884 one
newspaper, The Pall Mall Gazette,
had an incredible 79 interviews.
According to its most accomplished
interviewer, W.T. Stead,
interviewing was "the
most interesting method
of extracting the ideas of
the few for the instruction
and the entertainment of the many."
Another distinctive factor
of the interview is what I
call intimacy construction,
the story of the reporter usually
in the first person visiting
the politician or the writer
or the actor and writing
about that encounter
in an almost novelistic approach
and it wasn't until much later
that anyone thought of interviewing
the common man and I'm thinking
of Studs Terkel whose
amazing books as you all know,
I see lots of nodding heads,
The Good War, Working,
and Division Street, really kind
of broke the genre wide open
and it remains an incredibly
important tradition,
the Studs Terkel tradition,
and I would call
that the evocation school rather
than the provocation school
and it continued through new
journalism in the writings
of Gay Teleez [phonetic] who
in the early 60s was using sort
of evocative interviews to
stitch incredible stories
about Frank Sinatra and
Joe DiMaggio famously
and I would say it's even become --
, it definitely informs what's going
on here, absolutely, that you're
sitting down with the common folk
and evoking their stories and
kind of giving them a sense
of timelessness and taking an
appreciation of those words
that may be 50 or 60 years ago
wouldn't have been listened to
and that's certainly what
happens a lot in documentaries.
And I would say that's a
synthesis of oral history
and a collaborative interview.
So here's Joseph Pulitzer
and in the 19th century
and early 20th century he kind of --
, you know he's a famous newspaper
innovator and he endorsed a method
of interviewing that stressed
visual description and the evocation
of a sense of place and
it's been speculated that's
because he was partially blind
and he appreciated the importance
of detailed description
of interviewees in order
to communicate character so in a
memo to his editors he asked writers
to "stress the importance of
giving a striking vivid pen sketch
of the subject", also
a vivid portrait
of his domestic environment, his
wife, his children, his animals,
etc. and now we take
that for granted
but this was a complete innovation.
So in the 1920s and 1930s the form
of the interview was solidifying
into something we would
recognize today essay a cross
between a New Yorker profile
and a traditional Q&A.
For instance there is an astonishing
interview with Al Capone conducted
in 1931 and this is a great
line of character description,
"He leaned a bit further back in
his comfortable office chair and lit
for the 17th time is
Tampa cigar" [laughter].
So the postwar -- , and in
the post war the influence
of psychoanalysis I think
gave the interview more depth
and intensity while
television was kind of sliding
in the other direction especially
in the late 1950s and began
to exploit the appeal
of the attack interview
and most effectively Mike Wallace
and on YouTube there
is amazing footage
of him interviewing Frank Lloyd
Wright and it's a grilling,
not like what we see today,
but it's the beginning
of that really probing, difficult,
put you on the spot interview.
Wait for it, another click?
You're right.
So this is Truman Capote and he
elevated the interview into a form
of nuanced portraiture and
used manipulative techniques
to woo his interviewee into
confessional revelations
as he did spectacularly
with Marlon Brando in 1957
and I suggest you all read
that because it's quite striking
what he gets Brando to say.
But on the other end of the spectrum
and with growing popularity was the
celebrity interview as practiced
by Hollywood magazines in
the 30s and 40s and these
of course exploited the desire of
the audience to get an insider view
of the elegant glamour and
exquisite romance of Hollywood lives
and the fact that most of
those interviews were written
by publicists only intensified
their appeal because it made them
as artfully fictitious as the movies
in which the stars appeared in.
So authenticity in
interview was turned inside
out by the Paris Review whose
interviews starting in '53
with Faulkner, Hemingway,
[inaudible] were given back
to the writers for
post-interview editing and rewriting
and the argument was that they
believed, the Paris Review editors,
that this gave a clear and more
true essence of the interview
than a verbatim transcript
would've done and that's an argument
that still kind of exists today,
whether an edited interview cleverly
edited ethically is a compression
and is a more pungent distillation
of an interviewee's story
than just a verbatim transcript.
So finally I would
say the apotheosis
of the interview was Jen
Winters 30,000 word interview
with John Lennon that ran in
the 1971 issue of Rolling Stone.
Ramshackle and free-flowing it's a
remarkable portrait of an artist,
witty, cantankerous, opaque
and charming by terms and now
as I think all of us understand
we're in a splintered landscape.
Openness and spontaneity in
interviews with well-known artists,
actors and writers have all but
disappeared ironically at a time
when transparency and individuality
are declared to be the hallmarks
of the digital age and there are
few remaining pockets on radio
and podcasts but the
Facebook post, the selfie
and the tweet effectively
bypass the interviewer and allow
for a more curated and controlled
presentation of the self,
however for the everyday person
it's a wonderfully liberating moment
when people can tell their own
stories directly and powerfully
in ways not even imaginable
10 years ago.
On our cell phones we can interview
ourselves, our families, our lovers
and strangers and upload the
footage to YouTube or Vimeo
and broadcast our own explorations
of the inner landscape of others.
So I returned to Bromberg's
house about four or five times
and at first as you might have
experienced with veterans he stuck
to just to the broad
outlines of his war.
He was stationed in England
and his assignment was
to sketch some of the
soldiers there.
He watched the exercises
in preparation for of D-Day
at a place called [inaudible].
He was on the boats that
went over to Normandy.
He was there just after the
invasion and then he would tell me
about going through Europe partly
with the Third Army and into Paris
but it was very restrained and
I did want to dig in deeper,
I mean I did want to sort
of probe his inner landscape
and as I kept going back
and going back he loosened
up a little bit more and on the
third visit I noticed there's
another structure on the
property and he said oh,
he mentioned that his
daughter lived there
and on the third visit he said oh
I'm going to go show you my studio
and so I thought that's where your
daughter lives and he said no,
no it used to be my painting
studio and so we walked out there,
it was cold, and he gave
me a tour of his studio.
He showed me his sketchbooks
that he had sketched,
he had been sketching the whole
time, I mean that was a part
of his assignment and literally
as we were leaving the studio
and I kid you not I said what's
that cardboard box over there?
And he said oh, those
are my photographs.
And I said photographs?
And he said yeah, the
photographs I took during the war.
So, these are Bromberg's
photographs many
of which had never been seen before.
"Here I am with all this debris
of war, bodies, burned homes,
destroyed bunkers and minefields
and hedgerows and orchards.
For an artist this is an
exhilarating subject matter.
It was the biggest subject
matter you could get."
The journalists that I knew
they were thinking in terms
of the morning papers, the
deadline, getting the scoop,
and that's not what the artist
was there to do, make a scoop.
That's why they walked past
all this incredible stuff.
No one was interested
in the non-heroic,
that's what I was interested in.
I took all of these pictures and
I had no one to send them to.
So I'm interested in how you take
the raw material of an interview
such as an interview with
a veteran and transform
that into a narrative based on
facts but with the emotive power
of fiction so here's a test example.
Manuel Bromberg had his orders
folded neatly in his pocket,
two official pieces of paper
both from the War Department.
He was in the Army.
A carbine slung over his shoulder,
standard issue leather boots,
a sergeant's five stripes on his arm
but unusually a green
leather sketchpad in his hands
and a [inaudible] camera
slung from his neck.
Bromberg was an official
U.S. war artist.
His orders were to depict
the impact of war on you
as an artist, a human being.
The military had shipped
him to London.
He had spent almost a year
there waiting for action.
His assignments had been to
cover the mechanical crews
of the eighth Air Force tending the
B-17s as well as the American GIs
in the port city of Hull who
were unloading cargo ships.
He had made hundreds of drawings
of the men down on the docks
as they hauled and lifted.
Out on the airfields he was
captivated by the relationship
between men and machines.
Bromberg was struggling under
the burden of his mission.
The responsibility of observing
the day to day work of the soldiers
and then transforming those
observations into art.
In order to aid his memory
he would take a photograph
to capture the stance of a soldier
against the skyline or the angle
of the light or the
markings of an airplane.
But now Bromberg was standing
on Omaha Beach, D-Day plus six.
"The bodies were floating in.
It was a cross between
Dante's Inferno
and the biggest junkyard
I'd ever seen.
LST landing ships were
bashed in like tin cans.
German pillboxes blasted open.
Empty shells, twisted metal rods,
chunks of concrete
all littered the sand.
Jeeps and half tracks
everywhere, German POWs penned
in behind barbed wire like cattle."
A field hospital had been
set up in an orchard.
Big khaki Army tents like
circus hightops emblazoned
with medical crosses.
In the preop section of a
tent hung a white curtain
which marked the entrance to
the operating theater behind.
A doctor greeted Bromberg
and led him on a tour.
The medics had been
performing surgery
for almost 24 hours straight.
Soldiers lay on stretchers
everywhere even on the grass floor.
The doctor walked briskly
through the operating theater
to the rear of the tent.
He flung back the flap, Bromberg
peeked out expecting the worst.
Look at that said the doctor.
Bromberg looked around confused.
That's right said the
doctor, no arms, no legs.
We saved their arms and their legs.
Every minute, every few minutes
a dusty ambulance would pull up.
The wounded were streaming back
from the interior of Normandy
like sausages coming off the line.
The fighting in the hedgerows was
fierce, bloody and unexpected.
Bromberg was now back
inside the tent gazing
at a soldier stretched
out under the lamps.
He hated himself for thinking
it but the soldier looked good,
his arm flung back and his torso
vulnerable under the glare.
He took out his sketchbook
and drew furiously.
The soldier's midsection stripped
of his uniform reminded him
of Greek statues he
used to sketch as a kid
at the Cleveland Museum of Art.
He tapped his pocket
feeling for his papers.
"Our committee expects you always
to be more than a news gatherer.
Our choice was difficult.
Many of the finest
artists were physically
and emotionally unsuited
for this work.
His orders stated that
he was to depict the war
like Goya's famous series of
etchings, The Disasters of War,
that's what they actually said, to
depict the war like Goya he thought.
How the hell do they
expect me to do that?
"I didn't think historically,
the historians had to do that.
I was thinking pictorially,
artistically.
The artist has a whole
different set of problems.
How do I make this thing
really have timelessness?"
When the nurse moved away he lifted
his camera and took a picture.
So that's one experience of working
with an archive and now I'm going
to move on to a different
experience interestingly
that also did flow
from a BBC project.
This was a drama documentary
about Hiroshima.
It came out about six
or seven years ago
and it was very much a drama
documentary not in a cheesy way
but almost like halfway to a movie
and I was doing background research
and interviews in America, sort
of background interviews some
of them did appear
actually for the film.
And as often happens, similar story,
in the course of my research
I heard someone sort of --
, I think it was a historian
who said oh I heard this thing
with 700 photographs were found
in a suitcase on the street
in Massachusetts and you know
I don't really know about it
and it's kind of a mystery
and when the production was
over I thought well that's
a mystery worth tracking
down so I literally
got in my car and drove
up to Watertown, Massachusetts.
So one rainy night in
Watertown, Massachusetts,
a man was taking his dog for a walk.
On the curb in front of a neighbor's
house he came across a pile
of trash, old mattresses,
cardboard boxes, a few broken lamps
and in a heap of garbage he
spotted a battered suitcase.
He bent down and pulled it out.
He turned the suitcase over
and popped open the clasps.
Inside he found a jumble of
black-and-white photographs,
most of the bent, broken, water
stained, a few of them hole punched,
and they were images
of a ruined city
and he snapped the suitcase
closed, tucked it under his arm
and practically sprinted
home and standing
at his kitchen table he opened the
suitcase again and he was looking
at something no one
had really seen before,
the effects of the first
use of the atomic bomb.
So in a dispassionate and scientific
style the 700 photographs he found
inside the suitcase that evening
depicted a city seared by a new form
of warfare and now 70 years
after the bombing their
story can finally be told.
The mystery.
So the Deluxe Town Diner is a
classic airstream diner decked
out in high 1950s style
with the ivory
and turquoise exterior
and those glass bricks.
It's a diner as quintessentially
American as a Twinkie
and standing inside was a man
wearing brown corduroy trousers,
a dark blue sweater, tortoise
shell glasses and his hair was kind
of sticking straight up on top.
He kind of looked like a doofie
film professor [laughing] rather
than a diner owner.
His name was Don Levy, no
relation, and he was a connoisseur
of found objects and
finding the photographs
that night was obviously the
peak of his trash diving career
and he didn't know what to do
with them so he stuffed them --
, they were in terrible
shape as I said,
and he stuffed them into binders.
He put them into plastic sleeves
which you would all kind of groan
if you saw them and stuffed them
into binders and put the binders
in his basement and I asked Levy
when I turned up if he'd ever tried
to discover who owned the
photographs and he said
that it never really occurred to
him so I proposed that we try.
So we went to the town hall
and looked up all of the names
who had owned the house in front of
which the photographs had been found
and we googled the names on the list
and we came up with a phone number
for a man who had sold the house
in 2000, just around the time
that Levy had found the suitcase.
So we called him up on the phone
and literally his voice
shook with shock.
The photographs of Hiroshima?
You have them?
I must have thrown them out by
accident when I was moving my stuff
out of the house or
I left them there
and the new owners threw them away.
I never would have dumped them.
I've been carrying them
around with me since 1972.
So Mark Levitt, the former owner of
the house still lived in Watertown
so we invited him to come down to
the diner and over blueberry pie
and coffee we learned some more.
So in 1972 he and a friend had been
hired to clear out the basement
of a house in Westchester.
They were told to haul the
contents away to a dump
and Mark Levitt took
the photographs,
his friend really liked the look
of the trunk so he took the trunk.
He, Mark said, he was
haunted by the images.
He said something about
them overwhelmed me.
They don't represent the horror
exactly because there are no bodies.
They're clinical but the power
of them is really intense.
So a few weeks after meeting Levitt
I said look can you get in touch
with your friend Harlan and he said
I don't know I haven't seen him
for 20 years, but I
think it was five, six,
seven days later I got an email
from Harlan Miller, no message
but there were photographs
attached of a trunk sitting
on a kitchen table sort
of like an eBay photograph
from different angles
[laughter] and on the front
of the trunk it said Lt.
R.S. Corsbee [phonetic].
So the day after Japan surrendered
Truman commissioned the United
States strategic bombing survey
for the Pacific theater of war.
The mission of the survey was
"to measure precisely the impact
of the bomb, to put
calipers on it instead
of describing it in
a mode of terms".
So as part of the overall report the
team included something called the
physical damage division.
It was made up of 150 men including
engineers, ordinance experts,
interpreters, draftsman and
photographers and it was their job
to examine the physical effects
of the blast on the chimneys,
walls and reinforced concrete
structures that survived
and to explain and document the
impact, how the metal and concrete
and wood reacted to
the intense pressure
of the heat of the atomic bomb.
So soon after receiving this email
of the trunk I spent a few days
in the archives at the New
York Public Library reading
through the War Department's history
of the strategic bombing survey
and I confirmed that Corsbee
was actually part of group one
of the Physical Damage Division
and had arrived in Hiroshima
on October 8, 1945, and stayed
through the end of November.
So during those autumn months the
members of the division would fan
out across the city every
day to trace the blast paths,
calibrate the bomb damage and
analyze the physical destruction
of the city and it was is you
could imagine really tough going.
As late as November members
of the team still came
across human skeletons that
had not yet been cremated
and John Kenneth Galbraith
actually was one of the members
and he wrote the cities of Japan
in those dark autumn days was a
manifestation of unspeakable gloom,
only ashes and gaunt,
freestanding chimneys remained.
So in order to document the
damage, to identify, catalog
and really embalm Hiroshima for
further analysis seven members
of the Physical Damage Division
were tasked with the job
of taking photographs
of the destroyed city.
Trained as an architect Corsbee
was probably one of the draftsman
but he kept 700 of the work
prints and those were the ones
that ended up in the suitcase.
So a little bit about Corsbee.
Nancy Knight, Robert Corsbee's
granddaughter, was guarded.
Well, she said I'll give you
some background about our family
but you really have to
talk with my mother.
She's the only one
who survived the fire.
I was only nine at the time.
Fire I asked?
What fire?
You'll have to talk to
my mother but I will say
that I don't have many
memories of my grandfather,
I was just too young, but I do
remember that he used to sit me
down on his lap and we would
listen to Madame Butterfly.
Over the fireplace
hung two samurai swords
that he had brought back from Japan.
He joked that if I didn't
learn one of the arias
by the time I was 18 he was going
to cut my head off [laughter],
so along with the task of
documenting the devastation
of Hiroshima there was a second
goal, the data was to be compiled
to be used to help America to
survive a nuclear attack at home.
So here's the paradox.
At the moment of America's total
victory there was simultaneously an
awareness of the culture of the
country's future vulnerability
so the way out of that paradox
lay in the concrete structures
that had survived the blast.
In the words of The Survey
men arriving at Hiroshima
and Nagasaki had been
constantly impressed by the shells
of reinforced concrete
buildings that still are rising
above the rubble of brick and stone
or the ashes of wooden buildings.
The Physical Damage Division
studied those concrete shells
as if they were blueprints
for the atomic future.
So a few years after the war Corsbee
joined the Atomic Energy Commission
which I'm sure you all know, and he
was a bomb expert and as director
of the physical effects group
he brought his experiences
from Hiroshima directly
to bear on the testing
of the physical infrastructure
that the government was developing
in order to survive nuclear attack.
In other words he was
one of the first people
to design the U.S. military's
first atomic bomb shelters.
And according to a colleague
who worked with the AEC,
Corsbee was "quite a character, he
was a pretty hard high living guy.
He loved his drinking at night
and he was very energetic
and a sincere worker.
He did a great job at this thing".
Corsbee's daughter, Nancy
Mason, was more forthcoming
with her memories of her father.
I know that he was
traumatized by what he had seen.
He went through a bombed
out school in Hiroshima
and that got to him I know.
He brought home two burned
schoolbooks and a small sake cup
that had been blackened
by the blast.
I asked Nancy to tell
me a little bit more
about her father's
work with the AEC.
So he went out west to Nevada
quite a lot she told me
when I was growing up.
He was testing houses to see if
they could withstand nuclear blasts.
It was the time of duck and cover.
When I was in the sixth or
seventh grade he was on TV.
We got out of school early
to watch the footage,
to watch that live actually I think,
and they dressed him up in something
that looked like foil and they
dropped him by helicopter into one
of those test houses that
they'd blown up in the desert.
You've all seen that footage
of when the wind rocks
the house back and forth.
He was on the ground for all
of those, not on the ground,
he was dropped into
those houses afterwards
and they called him
the 24 carat hero.
So in 1962 Corsbee
left government service
and joined a private
practice as an architect.
He specialized of course
in designing buildings
that could withstand
nuclear or natural disasters.
For instance one of his largest
commissions, it's a bit strange,
was a design of an immense
underground blast shelter
for the Johnson & Johnson
company because they were wanting
to protect their herd of milking
cattle in case of a nuclear attack.
The fire. On the night of January 7,
1967, Corsbee's daughter had a date.
She was newly divorced
and she was planning
on dropping her nine-year-old
daughter off at her father's house
but at the last minute
her date canceled
and she decided to stay at home.
Early the next morning
the phone rang.
There had been a fire
at her father's house.
Corsbee's house was a nine bedroom
tutor mansion called Homewood
in Ossining, New York.
When Nancy and her daughter arrived
they were confronted by a house
that was totally devastated.
About 200 volunteer firefighters,
four pumper trucks and a hook
and ladder had been called to
fight the blaze but to no avail.
Robert Corsbee, his wife Evelyn
and their 22-year-old son
had all died in the blaze.
The first assistant fire chief
at the time was a man named
Richard Apostalico [phonetic].
Forty-four years later he
still remembered the fire.
It was one of the worst
I'd ever seen.
Some things you never forget.
The house was built like a fortress.
It had extra slate thick
roofs and the windows
where at least one
quarter of an inch thick.
We had a terrible time doing
what we call ventilation.
That's how you let the gases and
burning fumes out of a building.
It was something unreal.
We had pipe poles and we still
couldn't break the glass.
As a result of the unusual
construction the house contained the
fire like a furnace.
Apostalico found Mrs.
Corsbee in the foyer
about 35 feet short
of the front door.
When I got there he told
me I dragged her the rest
of the way out but it was too late.
According to the obituary in the New
York Times the following day she was
found fully dressed in a
skirt, sweater and a pair
of high heeled shoes beside her.
Then he tried to find Corsbee.
Battling the intense heat and smoke
it took Apostalico 20 to 30 minutes
until he found him dead
draped over a lounge chair.
He was trying to get
out of a side door.
He was close, about 15 feet
away, but he didn't make it.
According to the Times, Corsbee
was also fully dressed including
a necktie.
Because of the intense heat the
firemen had to suspend their search
and rescue and when they
resumed they found Robert junior
in his pajamas in an upstairs
bathtub full of water.
He was probably trying to keep away
from the flames said Apostalico
and he had died of smoke inhalation.
So the Corsbees had thrown a party
the night before which according
to witnesses they had
candles burning.
After everyone had gone home
they probably had a nightcap
on their living room
sofa and dozed off.
The candles in the living
room must have tipped
over accidentally said Apostalico
or burned down in such a way
that the drapery in
the room caught fire.
The drapery fell to the ground.
There was tremendous heat.
The fire was so hot that in the
kitchen which was 50 to 60 feet away
from the living room we found the
telephone trailing on the floor
like it was a piece of licorice.
Nancy Mason told me
that the contents
of the house were entirely
destroyed but down in the basement
where her father had meticulously
boxed, filed and stored all
of his records, almost
everything survived.
A few days after the fire
still reeling with grief
and shock Nancy Mason emptied the
contents of her father's house.
She cleared everything out of the
basement and she loaded the stuff
into her basement and she left
them there while she struggled
to reconfigure and
reconstruct her life.
So some five years later from that
she decided to weed things out
and she hired Harlan Miller
and Mark Levitt to get rid
of her father's effects and
drag them all and dump them
at the local dump and that's
when Harlan Miller salvaged the
photographs and Mark Levitt -,
sorry Mark Levitt took
the photographs
and Harlan Miller took the trunk
and Levitt stuffed the photographs
in an old suitcase which he
eventually brought to his house
in Watertown and stored in his
basement and when it came time
to move he either mistakenly threw
it away or he left it and the people
who bought the house threw it away.
Either way there it was left in
a pile of trash until Don Levy
out taking his dog for a
walk one night bent down
and popped open the clasps.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Robert Patrick: We
have a little bit of time.
Questions?
Okay, anyone have questions
or comments?
Yes.
>> First off where are the book
collections you were talking
about [inaudible] has his items?
>> Adam Harrison Levy:
Yes, so great question.
So Bromberg still has
the photographs.
He wants to put them together
in a book and there's talk
of an exhibition but it's all
very vague and the daughters,
I mean as you'll know from
-- , daughters are sort of --
, there's contention in the
family so we'll see what happens.
I mean it's been at least
five years but they are there,
they've been digitized, they're
safe and we'll see what happens.
As I said there are hundreds, not
as many as the Hiroshima photographs
and they are an incredible resource
so hopefully they'll
see the light of day.
I think they will, it's
just a bit of time.
The Hiroshima photographs,
a bit of a different story.
After I established the [inaudible]
and I wrote a short article actually
in The Guardian, ironically
it was the weekend
that there was the tube bombing
whenever that was, five years ago,
and so the staff at The Guardian
couldn't make it in and they had
to shorten the articles,
three people,
there was like a skeleton
staff and I don't think anyone
on that day wanted to read
about Hiroshima [laughter],
so it kind of sunk without
a trace I have to be honest
but there was a [inaudible]
established
and there was a circuitous route
but Don Levy was able to sell them,
I don't know for how much, I
don't think it was a lot of money,
to the International
Center of Photography
which now has the photographs.
They are online and there's an
exhibition that they mounted
as a result and they
are in the public domain
because they were taken
by the U.S. military.
These are the contact
prints not the negatives.
And the exhibition has never
traveled much to my chagrin.
I don't know why because
it's an amazing thing
but the ICP itself has changed,
they've just moved locations so it's
in their archive, it's accessible
and hopefully it will see the light
of day again but it has been
out in the public realm.
Anything else?
Yes.
>> So interviewing [inaudible]
so the artist his role was tasked
to document just like all history
is documented, so was it interesting
to interview him because he already
has a certain language already going
on that you could only beg
for from a regular Joe citizen
about their experiences?
So was his interview
different than any others
or [inaudible], what
was your thoughts?
>> Adam Harrison Levy: Well he
was definitely the U.S. war artist
so he didn't interview anyone.
I mean he hung out with the
troops but he was constantly --
, I think he was very
burdened by his --
, I mean you can tell
from his quotes,
I think he had a breakdown
while he was doing it.
He just could not square the
reality of trying to capture this
and this pressure being like Goya,
I mean that he kept coming back
to that but to answer your
question obviously he was an artist.
He was reflective about his process.
I think he was good at sort of
making links to the common soldier.
I did interview a lot of
people for the D-Day to Berlin.
I would say he's probably
more articulate than most
because he was introspective and he
was an artist and also because of
that experience, I mean it
forced him to think more deeply
about his failure to be honest.
Having said that you
know when veterans
and I know you've experienced
this, when they feel --
, you know it's a clich
but it's true
and there's a reason why
it's a clich they won't open
up to their friends, they
won't open up to their family,
they will definitely
talk to their colleagues
and their fellow combatants
but I also think historians have
an amazing opportunity especially
at the end of their lives
because they realize they're going
to pass away and this
is their last chance
and sometimes the most amazing
things are said and secrets
that have been kept for
40 or 50 years do come
out so that's incredibly meaningful
[inaudible] and it's great
that you're capturing that because
it is -- , you know, what, two,
three, four years from now
there's not going to be anyone.
[ Inaudible ]
I think this afternoon is going to
be more about the interview process
and what I go through in terms
of the nuts and bolts of how
to evoke a question or evoke
answers to ask the questions
that hopefully evoke the answers,
more like a workshop less of a talk.
Yes John?
>> You talk about evoking
rather than provoking,
how would you compare and
contrast the experience
of interviewing veterans
with interviewing celebrities
as you've done a bit
of that as well?
>> Adam Harrison Levy: Yes.
You know celebrities,
most of them have their --
, as you'd expect they have
their routine down so kind
of clinically sealed that to the
first question is really important,
like with a veteran you can kind
of start off relatively soft
and you probably should do because
they haven't been interviewed
but for like a real hardened movie
star I take a lot of time thinking
of what that first question is
going to be because you want
to signal this isn't going
to be just any old interview,
I'm not repping for PR, I'm trying
to get something that's a little bit
different so I spend a lot of time
on those first questions.
I think with celebrities
sometimes, I mean this is kind
of a funny story, it's good
to allow for the tangent.
Tangents are great in interviews
I mean you get a little nervous
if you think.
If you do really great research
you can have the confidence
that you're going to bring it
back to what I call the spine
of the interview but if you're
interviewing a celebrity sometimes
they go on a tangent sort of
to test you so here's a --
, I don't know why I
think of the story.
Jeff Daniels, it wasn't BBC, it was
channel 4, it was like 101 films
to see before you die, it was
like a list program and we were
to interview him about Dumb and
Dumber [laughter] and this is
like five years after the film came
out and obviously he has ambitions
to be more than a Dumb or Dumber
actor and he was on Broadway
and he's gone on obviously.
He's a really smart, intelligent
actor and he literally was
in a hotel room, just what you
don't want to do, small hotel room,
the lights were set up
and literally he came
down the hallway kind of slumping.
You could tell he didn't
want to do it.
He had his publicist kind of
like pulling him by the nose.
He sat down in the chair
and I didn't have a great
first question I have to admit
and I said can you describe
what you did in Dumb and Dumber
because we are doing this --
, I mean now this is kind of bold
[laughter], and he kind of looked
at me like come on buddy I've done
this so many times, forget about it
and I asked three questions and
I got those sort of no, yes,
no answers and I knew I was in deep
water and I thought I'm never going
to be able to use this so why not
just ask him a really tangential
question and I said
what are your hundred
and one films to see before you die?
And he kind of lit up.
He's like oh no once really asked me
that before and he started talking
about Buster Keaton films
and I was sitting there
and you know I only had
like 20 minutes and I was
like sweating thinking
where is this going to go
but I thought you know I'll see
where it goes and he started talking
about Buster Keaton and how he
walks and how buildings fall on him
and he has this incredible
physical grace and he's going on
and I see a little twinkle
in his eye and he said yes
and when I was walking through
the door in this scene in Dumb
and Dumber I was thinking
about Buster Keaton
and I thought that's all I need.
So he did know what he
was doing and so an actor
or celebrity have the gift
of knowing what you need
and they can play with
you a little bit.
A veteran might not necessarily
know what the soundbite is
but the celebrity, a writer, an
actor will know what you need
and they will either tease you
with it or they will give it to you
so that's a big difference.
Sure, yes?
>> Were there other war artists
and if so where are their works?
>> Adam Harrison Levy:
Great question.
There are more U.S. war artists.
They did not have the
funding or the support
that the British war artists had
and actually Bromberg was
really bitter about that.
They were literally when they
were in London they had bunkbeds
and no supplies and he
was really pissed off
because the British counterparts,
Henry Moore, Nash, Sutherland,
they all had studios and people
would come and visit them
and they had a whole -- ,
they had the Officers Club
and they were all taken very
seriously and to Sir Kenneth Clark
who went on to write Civilization
was in charge of their unit
so they were very protected.
In fact Bromberg would go visit
them and he was embarrassed
because he couldn't invite them back
anywhere, there was nowhere to go,
there was no Officers Club.
Having said that, and I
haven't done this research,
he said that there was an exhibition
of war art at Westminster Abbey
and he was there so some of
the American stuff did end
up in Westminster Abbey
with the British war artists
but it was definitely not
supported as much as the Brits did
and I think the program still -- ,
I mean you probably know, it goes on
and I think there were a number
of artists, right, in the Pacific.
[ Inaudible ]
I don't, I should.
Do you know their names?
And I think there was a book.
It wasn't actually a very good
book but it was a book of their art
and to be frank it wasn't
as good as the Brits,
I mean it really wasn't
which is a shame.
Having said that it
would be interesting
to find out what survives.
Who knows maybe some of
them also took photographs.
I mean he definitely was
issued with that [inaudible]
and that was a U.S. military
issue which is ironic
because it's a German camera
[laughter], but go figure.
I don't know how they
got hold of it.
All right, thank you so much.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at llc.gov.